18 Penn State fraternity members charged
in the death of a student pledge are
free on bail eight Beta Theta Pi members
made their first court appearance
yesterday 10 others went before a judge
last Friday the death of 19 year old
Timothy Piazza during a night of alleged
hazing has cast a harsh light on
fraternity rituals
Jericka Duncan is outside the courthouse
in Bellefonte Pennsylvania
Jericka good morning good morning those
fraternity brothers didn't have much to
say as they rushed in and out of the
courthouse yesterday while inside the
courtroom a judge explained to them the
charges they're facing asked them if
they had any questions and then set bail
any regrets about what happened that
night everything you'd like to say right
now none of the defendants spoke one
attorney did it's a very very troubling
and tragic and sad case we take it very
very seriously district attorney Stacey
parks Miller charged a total of 18 Penn
State University students with crimes
ranging from hazing to aggravated
assault the whole thing is disturbing
frankly it is the failure to get help
when he's injured and it is the
self-serving nature of the evidence
that's in the grand jury transcripts
according to the grand jury report
Piazza died from traumatic brain
injuries following a hazing ritual that
included heavy drinking at the Beta
Theta Pi frat house in February
the report says Piazza fell down a
flight of stairs and went in and out of
consciousness over a period of hours his
fraternity brothers allegedly waited
until the next morning to call 911 lence
cameras throughout the frat house
captured much of what happened that
night the videos essential piece of
evidence in this case it's literally a
playbook of the crime parks Miller says
in many ways that video brings to light
a long-standing culture of hazing
according to a 2013 Bloomberg news
report there were more than 60 deaths in
an 8 year span involving fraternities I
saw death eminent james daveggio was a
former Penn State student who claims he
experienced hazing at the hands of a
different fraternity
Delta Rho he filed a lawsuit in 2015
after he said Penn State officials
ignored his complaints in response to
mr. viv NGOs lawsuit the university said
a judge has already dismissed this case
but allowed one claim to be refiled we
are hopeful that the claim will be
dismissed again truly needs to be
stopped before more people fall victim
and you know lose the rest of their
lives to a three-letter organization the
university suspended Kappa Delta Rho
until 2018 the National fraternity
expelled nearly three dozen of those
Penn State members as for the fraternity
brothers involved in the Timothy Piazza
case well they are expected back here in
court next week for a preliminary
hearing
Gail can't stop thinking about the
Piazza family so disturbing and
heartbreaking and unnecessary thank you
jury kaveri much